what
kamal harris and what joe biden have
said
in regards to black lives matter which
essentially adopts many of the things
that you talk about
in cynical theories how do you reconcile
in your own mind
supporting them when you know that they
actually support
ideas that you repudiate in cynical
theories
i um
firstly there are a lot of other issues
as well so you're basically prioritizing
issues you're saying
okay i got i understand that they
support
these things that i abort but there's
other things that they
that they promote that i support so
you're saying
you have a number of choices in terms of
policies
you're going to choose to focus on what
you believe
to be um i i would say in the economic
realm
and and deal with the fact that
um you have challenges with their
support for things like black lives
matter
and um yeah there's there's
there's two issues there one of them is
that the
democratic platform is certainly a lot
more
than um the elements of it that support
critical social justice
and i think that on balance it is better
for
um american people than the republican
platform
but there's also the fact that biden
himself
is not a critical social justice
advocate he has said some
given some worrying lip service to it
but he has said that he will be a
president for all americans
now i was a huge fan of obama
and particularly the way in which he
criticized
um woke-ism and the idea that
um that you know if a black uh
student carrying a book is acting white
he he was what i would call a liberal
humanist
and biden as his vice president i think
did well
so i do not think biden is this radical
activist i think harris has made some
alarming comments
i'm particularly worried about um
aoc and her plan to um
create a list of trump supporters which
sounds
you know uh sort of approaching
yeah it's it's that's as we were talking
before this
my my whole um experience has been
focused on
china and the in particular the chinese
communist party how they have used
control of the narrative to define
truth within china and that has been a
very
um oppressive environment and what
you're what you're describing
is the beginnings it's at least it seems
on its face to be the beginnings of
something very similar
in the west and and i'm i'm guessing
based on the fact that you're from uh
the uk
that it's not just in the u.s it's also
happening in europe and other
democracies is that
fair yeah that that's absolutely fair i
tried to attend a symposium called
decolonized stem
where i intended to argue that actually
saying that science and
and maths and and um stem generally is a
white western male thing is actually a
bit sexist and racist
and i was uninvited from this symposium
because my views would apparently make
everybody else unsafe
so yeah we have you're a very
threatening person
yeah i'm um i'm i'm terrifying
apparently so
yeah that we have the same problem here
it's not
as overt and i think to a certain extent
this comes down to a difference in
natural
in in national character americans
simply are more straightforward and
direct that they'll
this is why i look a lot at what the
american theorists and activists are
saying
because they are explicit they will they
will come straight to the point here in
the uk
it's a lot more insidious you're less
likely to be um
called out publicly as as a racist and
um
and yeah our politicians are less likely
to say really radical things but you're
just sort of
likely to get quietly sidelined fired uh
failed so we have the same problem
um with a different kind of character to
it and of course we have a problem with
critical race theory being imposed on
um uk culture where it is even
less helpful than it is in the us
because it it simply doesn't work we
will hear
um anti-racists uh use the term bipoc
you know which means black indigenous
and people of color
now bipol doesn't work in the uk
indigenous britons are not people of
color
this isn't something that that makes any
sense but it's being
transported wholesale onto our political
political
taken so a term that kind of was
developed for the united states is being
impressed upon
the uk which has a completely different
um history yeah we have our own racial
problems
you know we have a very recent colonial
past in which we exploited
uh about a third of the world and so
yeah we have to deal with that but we
don't
most of the people that the uk um
exploited don't actually live here so we
have a different situation to the
ongoing
racial issues that you have in the us
and i i think i i have some sympathy
with a lot with some of your theorists
people like michelle alexander
for example it is undoubtedly true that
black americans have not
had the opportunity to rise within that
capitalist system that that you support
until a couple of generations ago
so it isn't really surprising that they
haven't um
caught up as a group yet and it's not
um i think unethical to look into
and support programs to to help them
actually do that